Comprehensible compelling input
is fine, but it's something
where we need an assist.
Hi there Steve Kaufmann here today
and I'm going to talk to you today
about CI, which can be compelling
input or comprehensible input.
And I'm going to talk
about the limits of CI.
Uh, remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
Uh, if you're on a podcast service,
uh, you know, please leave a review.
I appreciate it.
So, uh, if you follow me on these,
on my YouTube channel, you'll know
that I'm a great believer in Stephen
Krashen's input hypothesis that
we learn languages through input.
And that ideally that input should
be, and input means essentially
listening and reading, um, that that
input should be comprehensible and
meaningful and ideally compelling.
And so this then is the term CI and
there's a whole range of teaching
activities that have developed around
this concept of creating CI, compelling or
comprehensible, of course, for input to be
compelling, it has to be comprehensible.
It can be comprehensible and boring.
But it can't be, it's difficult for it
to be compelling and not comprehensible.
Uh, although it can be of great interest,
but you don't fully understand it.
So to that extent, it's semi
comprehensive, but very compelling.
But at any rate CI, ingesting
comprehensible, compelling
input, meaningful messaging
as Krashen refers to it.
The more of this quantity of meaningful
messages we get the more our brain
starts to become familiar with
the language and we acquire words
and familiarity with the language.
And eventually we end up being
able to speak the language.
So I do believe in the power of
CI and I think these methods, new
methods of language instruction
built around CI are good, but I
also feel there are certain limits.
First of all, when we start in a new
language, nothing is comprehensible
because you don't know the
language, you're starting at zero.
Obviously if you're going from
Spanish to Portuguese, some
things are comprehensible.
At least when you read, even as an
English speaker, if we see something
in French or Spanish, there are
words there that we recognize.
So some things are comprehensible but
generally speaking, especially if we're
listening to it, it's not comprehensible.
So to start off, you know, right
at the beginning, you know, we can
start with comprehensible input.
So we have to have some way of
getting, you know, stepping ourselves
up, empowering ourselves up to a
point where we are actually able
to deal with comprehensible input.
As I've said, that's where I
use the mini stories at LingQ.
Because the...
and I like the idea of
a lot of repetition.
I have a high degree of tolerance
for repetition of relatively
uninteresting content, because I'm
very motivated at first to at least
get a toehold in the language.
After a while, I get tired of this,
but initially I'm quite capable of
subjecting myself to, uh, repetitive
content, repetitive listening, repetitive
reading, looking up words, uh, in
order to get a toehold to the language.
The second thing about comprehensible
input, and I've read now quite a bit on
the subject, people like Paul Nation in
New Zealand and others, uh, there's a lot
of raw material available on the internet.
If you search comprehensible
input, extensive reading, uh,
you can find lots of information.
And one of the sort of traditional
approaches to this idea of, of using
input to acquire the language is to
say that using the example of the
native speaker who apparently learns
a thousand words a year and the native
speaker learns a thousand words a year
because the native speaker has so much
exposure to his or her own language,
whether it be listening or reading.
And so the native speaker doesn't need
to look words up the native speaker can
infer meaning, can guess at meaning,
gets these words in so many different
contexts that they simply become
part of the sort of active vocabulary
words and phrases, expressions, new
expressions, and use slang words.
They hear them on TV.
They read them here or there, and
that becomes part of their vocabulary.
Um, for someone learning a foreign
language, it's more difficult.
So, uh, there was one paper I read, which
talked about maximum 2% unknown words.
So that's one in 50 unknown words, that's
kind of the level you need to be at so
that you can sort of naturally learn these
words by guessing, or by encountering
these words in different contexts and
gradually getting a sense of what they
mean, you know, to acquire words that way.
Uh, it would be tremendously
time-consuming because as I've said,
many times frequency drops off.
So for the first thousand words
where there are a lot of what they
call function words like, uh, you
know, "the", "and", uh, "by", "with",
"from", "I", "you", "he": common verbs.
That's all there in the first thousand.
And we get those so often
that we learned them.
There it is possible to acquire them
through, acquire them through context
in, in more or less comprehensive input.
It's not, in my opinion, if you're
dealing with a foreign language, if
I were to start on, Finnish on LingQ,
I would want to look up every word,
I want to know which word is "by"
or "with", or "because", and I'll
forget it, but I'll look it up again.
And that way that speeds me along.
Otherwise I will just be looking at the
string of five words and I don't, I don't
know which one is the verb, which one is
"by", "with", "because", "from", "and".
I look them up and eventually I
remember what I looked up, not
at first, but I do eventually.
And, but never...
in any case, the first
thousand words are easier.
The second thousand words,
we're now dealing with words
that don't show up that often.
Where you would have to, because
again, theoretically, you need to
meet a word eight times, according
to some research in order to have a
50% chance of remembering that word.
Uh, words that don't show up
very often that might show up
five times in a whole book.
Uh, you've got to read a lot of
books in order to meet that word
often enough to remember it.
And particularly if you're relying on, you
know, inferring or guessing the meaning
of that word, if you're able to look it
up, if as at LingQ you have differential,
you know, uh, highlighting to remind
you that you've seen the word before.
If you have, you know, lists that you
can review after you finish a lesson,
all of these different things can help
you, you know, acquire these words
more quickly so that you don't need
to rely on being able to read through
material that is so easy for you
that there's only 2% unknown words.
You actually can read material
that's more difficult.
Uh, and that way by using something
like LingQ, or if, even if you're
reading on your Kindle and you look
up words in a dictionary or whatever
it might be, uh, you're able to deal
with more than 2% unknown words.
And every time you look the word
up, you tuck it away somewhere.
You forget it, but you're
working your way through.
You're making that input comprehensible.
You're not deliberately trying
to hang on to those words.
You're making the input comprehensible
and in time, those words as you meet
them again and again, are going to
become a part of your vocabulary.
So again, comprehensive or
compelling input is fine, but it's
something where we need an assist.
Another assist is audio.
If you can hear it as well
as listen to it, you get some
momentum into your reading.
You get sort of a combined
effect, which is again, going to
help you retain the vocabulary.
And ultimately the goal is to acquire
enough vocabulary and familiarity with the
language that you can read more and more.
So it's a bit of a snowball situation.
The more words you have, the more you
words you can learn, the more you're
enjoying the process, because as you
acquire more words, you can deal with
content that's of greater interest.
And of course you can choose to
focus your activities so that,
you know, what determines...
I mentioned this system in the
UK, where they wanted to say,
you must learn these 1700 words.
Well, if my interest is in nuclear
physics, or it's in nature or it's
in economics then I might actually
acquire and learn and remember some
very low frequency words that are
relevant to my area of interest.
And so we can actually control to some
extent what low frequency words we're
going to encounter and make sure that
we encounter them over and over again.
And then every so often we can
change to another call it "domain"
where we again will be encountering
words somewhat more frequently.
We can have a strategy along those
lines, uh, at, at LingQ, we like to know
what percentage new words there are in
any content you want to import or any,
anything you may find in our library.
And typically for me, 15% unknown
words is kind of a sweet spot.
I know that that if I were to spend
time and effort to listen to and read
items with about 15% unknown words,
I'm going to be really improving,
increasing, you know, creating more LingQ.
As we say at LingQ, adding
to my vocabulary, improving
my ability to understand more
and more demanding material.
So, uh, the idea that sort of
comprehensive input, just go out
and read and enjoy yourself, I think
is a little more complex than that.
Uh, I think if you rely solely on being
able to infer meaning, uh, without
looking words up in the dictionary,
without making that a little extra
effort to learn the words, the amount of
material that you would have to consume
would be hours and hours and hours.
And on the other hand, There are so many
words to learn that if you were to rely
solely on say flashcard activities like
Anki, then you would deny yourself the
pleasure of listening and reading the
whole familiarity with the language that
comes through that kind of activity.
So you need a bit of a
mixture in my opinion.
Something between purely extensive
reading or on the other hand, deliberate
vocabulary study in order to make that
input, you know, push you forward.
And there's no question that if
you can achieve a high level of
comprehension, both oral and written,
your speaking ability will come along.
And all of that doesn't require you to
be, you know, totally accurate in your use
of grammar that will improve over time.
And shouldn't...
testing you on grammar, which is
often discouraging, shouldn't be
sort of an obstacle to getting people
moving forward in the language.
So comprehensible input as the
core, but sensible comprehensible
input where modern tools are used to
help people progress more quickly.
That's what I think is most effective.
And, uh, I'll leave you a couple
of videos that I've done on
similar subjects in the past.
And again, remember, please
subscribe to my videos and
please send along your comments.
Thank you for listening.